[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté je crois qu'on va s'amuser
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya plein de
choses à faire mais bien trois ou quatre
recettes est très facile tout les 4 est
très amusant et assez original alors ça
je me réjouis
alors dites-nous ce que c'est on va
faire du jambon au cidre du jambon au
l'idée aux pauvres vers huy et des
confitures exotiques et c'est pour ça je
dis ça va être très amusant
alors qu'est ce qu'il nous faut pour
tenir c'est beaucoup de choses pour
toutes les recettes et il faut des idées
il faut du vin blanc il faut du cid
il faut des noix de coco il faut des
ananas il faut dessus d'autres cas du
sucre de canne sucre roux voilà il faut
de citron vert
il faut des pommerats tous à de la crème
fraîche réunion il faut du pauvre vert
il faut de la poudre de la noix de coco
râpée
ap et bien entendu un superbe jambon
alors ça m'a aidé c'est un jambon du
pays basque voudra des aldudes de la
vallée des adultes ravissante les essais
des petits cochons que nous connaissons
bien puisqu'ils sont venus ici sur
l'action venu avait le cul noir et lille
reste tout rose il dit marge des
châtaignes la saison qui vivent en
liberté en haut de la montagne sont tous
panache est tout mignon et délicieux
quoi alors la noix de coco il se trouve
qu'on en a déjà parlé longuement étant
donné qu'on a fait des émissions on a
fait toute une émission so what corlay
on a montré comme on l'a cassée et
comment la rapée comme on l'a rappelé et
c'est du travail
voilà et aujourd'hui on va voir comme on
en fait de la confiture mais pour
commencer
qu'allez-vous faire briller eh bien on
va faire le jambon au lille et au port
vers la vous découper une superbe
tranche mais le relais pourquoi il ya un
grave selon un oui je sens que vous
entrez bizarre c'est le meilleur des
jambes on va me dire le maigre le mec
aubry s'en servir
le gras c'est bon à manger comme ça bien
sûr mais bien sûr que c'est bon alors
vous enlever un peu de wazemmes et tout
ça pour sortir sa part à quoi nous c'est
le graal français de la branche
et qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait et je le
poids
tout simplement sur une toile où vous
n'avez rien il y en aurait pas eu de
bons dans l'autre point vous avez mis
des oignons en réseau et en revenir et
je vais y rajouter les pommes coupées en
ab sorti la fois le pourquoi sabrina et
un silo et je vais y rajouter ses formes
ils vont plus intime à avec cet oignon
sur une finale non je crois que ça soit
très bon surtout la voilà alors ça ça va
cuire mode le grade on leur tourne
évidemment il va finir après de cuir
avec vous toute manière il faudrait que
le cuivre non il faut qu'il soit quand
même à domaine
voilà alors vous vous donnez l'assiette
que je le sorte là et je vais le garder
au chaud peut-être gardé le chômage
était en cours et là je vais rajouter un
petit peu de jus de jambon
ceci ne va rien gâcher là pour rien de
se perdre et ça ça va cuire
tranquillement et on va attendre que
tout ça se cuisent pendant combien de
temps
bon il faut sa cuisine 10 minutes voilà
là on voit très bien bouclé bien comme
il faut
qu'est ce que vous en faire l'un funeral
petit peu de vin blanc le vol a beaucoup
ri glas du vin déglacer au vin blanc
et là maintenant le cidre le voilà il ya
des spécialistes et je vais recouvrir
ses pommes de cidre et ensuite bien
entendu mais il faudra attendre que ça
réduit encore le cidre est presque
complètement il appauvrit vous allez
passer ça maintenant n'ont pas encore je
vais rajouter de la crème fraîche
là sera bien enrichir le tout est
maintenant votre passé regardez moi ça
c'est odieux
si c'est beau et appétissant on le passe
on y va on le passe et voilà un petit
coup de mou lynette et ça fait la bonne
petite sonde ans et l'oignon la pauvre
le vin blanc le cidre et la crème
circulant ça ne peut pas être mauvais
succulent regardez-moi ça si ces bourses
voilà alors et la gema tranches de
jambon quelques quartiers tels qu'on
avait ce point les juste un tout petit
peu au beurre la juste doré et voilà le
légume et voilà un plat pas compliqué et
délicieux avec le bon jambon et qu'est
ce qu'on fait maintenant
le jambon au lillers et on peut refaire
vous avez coupé une nouvelle et très
belle tranche mérité un petit sentez
vous la fait poiler aussi je l'apprenne
pratiquement à sec et vous allez avoir
les traits sont justes et ville de cette
zone le passé l'assiette vous l'a
retourné à côté vous avez mis des
oignons se voit aux et la rondeur qui
commencent à dorer son parfait bonbons
et des oignons temps passé voilà le beau
graja translucide ça va très bien joué
ce soir c'est joli donné le qu'est ce
que vous faites des rognons je vais des
glaciers tout de suite pardon avec de
lille et la poigne à le supplément
[Musique]
un petit peu de bouillon
oui la regarder sa fille c'est joli et
là je vis verser mes oignons
ils sont revenus yang aurait remué de
tout regarder ça fait seulement faire
réduire parce que c'est comme il faut
j'ai parfait je vais y mettre le poivre
vert que voilà la rd57 appétissant
ensuite la crème fraîche
c'est amusant parce que c'est très
différent de l'autre et ça va être quoi
très délicieux c'est pareil ça n'est pas
pareil
la maïté comme amendé son excuse si on
vient à la maison on est fatigué on dit
on fois faire la cuisine
on va aller au fast food dans la
restauration rapide
eh ben on est impardonnable parce que
vraiment là ces cinq minutes un 10
minutes et vous rend dans l'assiette de
chambon cinq minutes la série 5 minutes
et c'est quand même la version afin cela
et moi je vais vous versez c'est quand
même autrement en plus attendre une
meilleure que la restauration
industrielle regardez un peu la
compagnie avec un petit légume ce qu'on
a sous la main vous voulez ou des pâtes
ou des pommes de terre mais des pommes
de terre bouillies donné dans une
cocotte la hausse ses superbes séries
mais là il faut plus de cinq minutes on
a été unanime nous n'allons pas rêver
trop nous il faut retomber sur terre on
a des confitures et de tic à faire
encore on a fait de toutes sortes de
pastèques d'abricot de poire de ceux de
fraise et de cerise et au jour tout le
monde sait faire ça dans notre monde
quand même dans toutes les régions mais
alors aujourd'hui voulais faire quelque
chose de différent et le co feature
d'ananas et bien voilà et qu'est ce
qu'il vous faut pour cette confiture
d'ananas de la nana bien entendu une
jolie va dire du sucre de canne bien
joli du citron vert
evreux là et l'ananas coupé en morceaux
ah oui quand même alors qu'elle en fait
vous mais alors je prends l'avenir je la
coupe en deux pour qu'il y ait des
graines pour que ce soit bien prendre le
maximum de points
alors on met l'avenir les deux je mets
des fruits la moitié un peu de jus de
citron probablement assez vite après le
jeune demi jus de citron parce que m à
l'autre la travers il est bien juteux et
qu'est ce que je remarque c'est les
proportions quand même dont il faut
tenir compte
vous m'avez dit que vous aviez à peu
près 700 grammes d'ananas pour une livre
de sucre roux oui c'est beaucoup de sud
par rapport à la nana oui il faut faire
attention qu'il a fait beaucoup
d'efforts et beaucoup de sucre voilà on
est la moitié après je vais finir de
mettre tous la main je vais remettre le
citron l'autre moitié de citron la
vanille de rester aux formes terriens
vernet ce niveau une gousse de vanille
ça suffit je vais finir d'y mettre le
sucre et on va laisser sa 24 heures à
macérer tranquillement voilà le temps
ayant passé l'ananas a lâché
passablement de jus et quant au sucre
fonde il a donné une couleur assez
extraordinaire le regardera mail caramel
blond et puis le par saint-jean dit rien
mais ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai
goûté c'est délicieux qu'est ce que vous
en faites maintenant eh bien on va le
cuir
évidemment tout simplement et comme tout
les confitures et il faut cuire assez
longtemps 45 minutes à feu doux il en
voit une horreur bus entre de sucre
pendant 45 minutes avait remué
tranquillement je pense que ces prêts à
présent vous ne croyez pas voilà
quarante cinq minutes
ça vous paraît bien alors les terminer
ou pas tout à fait alors il n'y a pas
grand-chose à faire passer on va la
passer
selon elle la vanille à qui va vous
gêner
sans plomb ça c'est pas facile de faire
passer mais bien la confiture il faut
trouver des morceaux alors vous avez une
petite grille peut-être un peu fine
aussi enfin de toute manière c'est
maintenant c'est pas grave
regardez ce qu'on va faire don ou les
petits morceaux ce sera des lissiers
sous la halle et bien sûr et donc la
plus qu à mélanger un peu et on va le
mettre dans un peu au regard des
combinés joly traitée alors n'a regardé
ça c'est la famille ça ne va pas gâcher
la très bien aller fermer le pont
micheline et ensuite qu'est ce qui nous
reste à faire la confiture de coco nous
avons la noix de coco nous avons là sa
chère à l'intérieur qu'on a rappé un
gros travail et là nous avons à peu près
400 g de noix de coco fraîche
rappelez vous de votre côté qu'est ce
qu'on va leur gérer un demi litre d'eau
et un kilo de sucre de cannes vient vous
ce que vous et vous l'avez fondu vous
ajoutez quoi alors la vanille est coupé
en deux le bâton de vanille coupée en
deux et je vais mettre toute cette
poudre dans tout ce qu a perdu ce coco
et je vais faire cuire 45 minutes en
remuant
voilà tout doucement doucement
il est temps de présenter nos plats
maintenant oui alors là nous avons le
premier que nous avons fait c'était le
jambon au cidre et aux pommes et puis là
celui là c'est le jambon au lille et au
poivre vert qui délicieux aussi ça c'est
la confiture d'un an ce qui est
excellente écoute et elle est très bien
comme consistance et délicieuse comme
parfum je crois que c'est quelque chose
de précieux est bon sa bonne recette
et si à la la et là c'est la confiture
de coco de noix de noix de coco qui est
succulent c'est à dire qu'après tout
c'est cuissots la noix de coco est
devenu complètement translucide
alors si on le mange assez rapidement
n'y a pas besoin de les stériliser vie
vaut mieux sinon c'est une précaution
et puis c'est tellement facile alors
vous a donné quatre cents
vous ne pouvez pas les rater c'est
enfantin
salon l'appel du premier coup et
exactement et elles sont bonnes alors au
revoir et à bientôt
bon appétit à bientôt
[Musique]